Roopkund Lake in India
is sixteen thousand feet above sea level
a glacial lake, and it is overflowing with skeletal remains
but the real amazing thing about skeleton lake
is what killed the people that are there
So in 1942 this Indian forest ranger
stumbles across Roopkund Lake
and sees that it is full of skeletons, it is full of the remains of hundreds of people...
looking back up through the frozen ice in this lake
it would have been an absolutely terrifying sight!
So this forest ranger became concerned that these might be Japanese soldiers
as part of some kind of WWII maneuver
and reported it to the British
But on a follow up study in the 1950s
they found that these skeletons were in fact much older than that
but even after this forest ranger discovered them
they don’t know how they got there, and they don’t know what killed these hundreds of people
dozens of theories were put out
ancient soldiers
a caravan of merchants
a royal wedding party
maybe they died of disease
maybe they all froze to death
this mystery goes unsolved for decades
there were some songs and stories that were told
that lent some possible explanation to how these people came to be there and what killed them
In 2005 as part of a National Geographic expedition
they begin examining the skeletons
and they find some interesting things
one: it’s a mixed group. There are women, there are children there are older people
they think they may have been other way to a festival
celebrating Nanda Devi
all of these skeletons suffer from similar wounds
blows to the heads and shoulders with a blunt object
this area of India, because its in the mountains, in the Himalayas
16,000 feet above sea level, over a glacial pass
the weather is out of control there
the area is also known for extreme hailstorms...
and that is what killed all of these people
the songs and folklore
were about the Goddess Nanda Devi becoming angry at a traveling party
in an act of rage she cast down stones as hard as iron
striking all of these people dead
and all of the scientific evidence, all of the forensic evidence
backs this up
they were killed when a freak hailstorm started dropping
hailstones that were as big as nine inches in diameter
that is what killed the people at skeleton lake
a friggin hailstorm!
so while it may have taken until 2005
to definitely prove with science
that the hundreds of people at Roopkund were killed in a freak hailstorm
the stories, the song of the area, have been telling this tale for over 1100 years
subscribe here and watch more videos here
people steal the skeletons, they are slowly being taken
the region is trying to get the area earmarked, designated as a protected region
leave them at the lake, it’s skeleton lake, its what it’s named after them
leave them there